my name is Jake and I'm here with Cali
plaguey we're here at e3 2017 and we
both just played some Assassin's Creed
origins finally after waiting a long
time for this game to finally get
revealed so we're gonna give you guys
some impressions of it
who are you what do you want that I'm
buyer to see what and I seek information
on the crocodile first of all it is an
Egypt the leaks were true and we really
like the Egypt setting I'm big Egypt
nerd and I just liked that it you know
you see Anubis and jackal heads and
stuff like that so it's fun to explore
that and to sail the Nile
yeah and in true Assassin's Creed
fashion it's very detailed yes it seems
like everywhere you go people have their
own schedules that they're following
some people go to work so go to bed and
that is actually new to the Assassin's
Creed franchise normally NPCs just kind
of blunder around the map or the world
but in this they actually made a point
that each even the animals apparently
have their own schedules that they
follow which i think is cool that adds a
lot to the world and you may or may not
encounter a crocodile or a hippo and it
may or may not detect you and you can
fight it and that's pretty much happen
to both it haven't had sunk by ship um
and horseback riding is back and it is
it is very important to this game the
world is huge and it's all seamless like
switch switching from horseback to the
boats - you have that Eagle you can
control overhead that can see like
waypoints and things around you all of
that transitions really seamlessly yeah
in you can walk right up into buildings
I don't think I saw single loading
screen except when I died but another
thing another drum they're hitting
really hard with this is this is more of
an RPG than past games you know talk
about that a little bit yeah they
specifically called it an action RPG so
rather than being an action-adventure
game or a stealth game they're really
really hitting the RPG stuff so there's
a skill tree which branches out until
like you can kind of customize to be a
hunter or Archer or you know brute force
warrior or it be a little bit more
stealthy and tricky and you can blend
those because they all are in this light
web so they're not separate trees which
is really cool so you can kind of if you
want to be a sneaky Archer which is a
play style I really like doing that
it's really cool to have more control
over how you be in assassin yeah it adds
a lot more to it it doesn't feel like
just in a beautiful-looking action game
it's more it seems like it's got a
little bit more depth to it thanks to
those systems and there's loot too so as
you progress you'll be getting you'll be
leveling up you'll be getting different
armor sets different cloaks different
weapons and that ties into combat a lot
of those RPG elements have to do with
the combat which is a little tweaked it
was very dark souls like don't talk
about that a bit yes so each weapon you
pick up for the most part like their
swords their spears there's hammers have
different sort of play style which is
similar to Dark Souls in that sense but
it's also it's you've got your heavy
attack on the right trigger and then
you've got your your weaker attack on
the bumper and basically what you want
to do is get around your enemies watch
their patterns and strike it remind me a
lot of Dark Souls yeah a lot more easier
yeah countering and reading the opponent
was really really important I died
because I was just trying to do like a
more Assassin's Creed style thing it
doesn't feel like Assassin's Creed which
I thought was refreshing yeah it's I
think it's much harder than the original
Assassin's Creed games it's it requires
a bit more from the player which I
really enjoyed but you said you weren't
totally in love with it though I thought
it was a little bit clumsy part of that
was adjusting to a new game obviously
but some of the movement was a little
weird there were parts where I was
trying to like come down from a Ledge
and it didn't quite work or I dove into
water when I just wanted to drop down to
a Ledge so there were things like that
that kinks that might get worked out
when the game is finished obviously it's
not done but there was stuff like that
where movement and because movement is
so important to this kind of combat it
felt a little encumbered to me so I'm
waiting just I'm waiting to see if I
like that after I play a little more so
having played for about an hour each
what is your overall opinion of
Assassin's Creed origins well I think
it's really cool they're really striving
to be a bonafide open-world RPG and
that's really really intriguing to me
and I'm actually really excited for this
game when I haven't been excited for it
it has ins creaking in forever and in
Egypt of course is a phenomenal setting
I think there's so much mystery to Egypt
a lot of people are really fascinated by
it that they have room to tell a really
really interesting story yeah I agree as
someone who's not a huge Assassin's
Creed fan in fact I don't really like
those games that much this one has me
very excited it reminds me a lot of The
Witcher which is cool we also got to
play on the Xbox one X which was really
cool it looked really beautiful and with
all those things combined it was a
really nice package so that's what we
thought of Assassin's Creed origins if
you enjoyed this video make sure to
subscribe and stay tuned because we've
got plenty of more III stuff coming your
way
[Music]
[Music]